depth throughout there is no secret that
we need to get better at wideout we
understand that we really like adding
melts and angle art but we plan need to
get better at wideout and again kind of
like the corner conversation and I think
you got to let it come to you a little
bit and whether it's in the first round
checked around third down fifth round
I'm hoping you can kind of wide out if
it's what the what the Raiders need and
their culture mike Mayock general
manager of the raiders his pre-draft
press conference and look after the
antonio brown debacle last year and the
havoc it wreaked on the receiver room
obviously the Raiders need help in that
area and all due respect to Nelson
Aguilar that's not the help that they
need to get them to where they need to
be so as we look at the AFC West teams
Chris let's begin with the Las Vegas
Raiders I fear I've already said Oakland
at least twice the Las Vegas Raiders
can't leave the 2020 draft without what
well I think it's I got to just echo
what he just said it is the wide
receiver position I mean I can't sit
here and like pretend that's anything
else they obviously have other holes on
their roster you know you could argue
yeah they could use some more help in
the secondary all right but the wide
receiver first off Jon Gruden he's an
offensive coach you know they want to
win football games with being able to
throw the football effectively and score
points and play a certain style of
football how do you really know who
Derek Carr is and if he's you really
your guy unless you put some proper
talent around him to be able to evaluate
to know whether he's really your guy too
so I would argue that so this is more
about you know hey will they take a
receiver at 12 I don't know if CD lamb
was on the board I would be I would run
or text message in and quickly as
possible to get let's get him in there
but they need more than one receiver to
it's not just it's just not just one I
wouldn't be shocked if we saw them take
one at 12 and then take one again and in
the third fourth round somewhere in the
middle of the draft as well I remember
it was last week that Eric to cause to
the Ravens GM said you could find a
starting receive
in round five this year so you're right
you can get multiple receivers see who's
on the board at 12 if you're not happy
with who's there at 12 see who's there
at 19 they don't have a second round
pick but they do have opportunities
later in the draft to bolster that
position and I agree with you they
definitely need to do it and they need
to give before they pull the plug on
David on Derek Carr which they very well
may do they need to at least give him a
chance to thrive like you said I mean
what great receivers has he really had
during his time as the starting
quarterback they thought they had a
Antonio Brown we all know how that went
down they need to find somebody who can
come in and be that number one option
open up the rest of the offense because
everyone's focused on stopping that guy
whoever it may be
all right the Chiefs defending Super
Bowl champions cannot leave this draft
without what Chris I think I look at
middle linebacker as being the position
that pops out the most to me I mean
certainly you know where they sit at 32
you know my mind and brain like spin a
little bit Mike and I go oh my gosh if
Clyde Edwards Hilaire from LSU was on
the board at 32 and they could have a
guy like that with Tyree kill and Kelsey
and Watkins going deep and then you got
a guy like Edwards Hilaire working the
underneath I mean that would be
unstoppable
there's a part of me that wants to say
that but I think the linebacker spot is
more of a need for this football team
and they might be able to get a really
quality football player there at pic32
but nonetheless at some point during the
draft it has to be a position that first
off it lacks depth for the Kansas City
Chiefs and does not really a whole lot
of high-end talent there either they
have Anthony Hitchens but they need
another body to go along with him
especially when they've had injuries the
last few years they better put Daniel
Sorensen in there who's a third safety
and play him I think more than they
would like so I look at that as being a
huge spot for them run defense has not
been one of the strengths of the Kansas
City team either the last few years and
a linebacker I think would go a long way
to helping that out last year when
LeSean McCoy was cut by the bills right
at the end of training camp in the
preseason when the rosters were reduced
to 53 the Chiefs swooped in and added
him he was a disappointment relative to
what we'd seen from him in the past
Damian Williams held the starting job
but remember this
Le'Veon Bell acknowledged that prior to
the trade deadline there were multiple
teams inquiring about getting him from
the Jets and one of them was the Chiefs
and we've in the past speculated on what
a guy like levy on bail could do for
that Chiefs offense holy crap give him
the next two or three Super Bowl
trophies if they had a guy like that to
complement the passing game yeah I feel
like that's that's that's what they
might hear you looking for and how much
better that offense would be and I don't
want to I guess I am denigrating the
skills that Damian Williams I mean he
had the big touchdown at the end of the
Super Bowl that was the dagger for the
49ers
he had a great 90-yard touchdown run
against the Vikings that really turned
the tie their a game they were gonna
lose at home without Patrick mahomes on
the field but I feel like that's what
they need to make the offense already
the best offense in the NFL even better
to be as good as they are offensively
without that workhorse running back is
amazing and they get Mike any of the top
three or four Jonathan Taylor Clyde
Everett or any of the top three or four
running backs and one of those guys is
gonna be there at 32 without question
there's not going to be a run running
backs in round one no I mean you know my
thoughts Mike I really think Clyde
Edwards Hilaire and Jonathan Taylor are
the only two first-round talents at the
running back position Mike you know I
you might have swayed me really there I
was between running back I mean that's
why I had that long spiel about the
running back position I mean you make a
lot of great points I really do it I
think it's down to those two positions
and you know you know to what you're
saying Mike I'll bolster your argument
for the running back a little bit you
know hey we know they're gonna win games
with their offense that's how they're
built so why not just strengthen that to
to it agree and make it just so
unstoppable and have so many different
weapons coming at you that they really
you know compromise your football team
with the ability to stop them so yeah I
think there's a lot of merit to that I
just wonder what they'll do with that
first pick in the first round you know
well they do the linebacker there and
then maybe get the running back in the
second round or vice versa I think it
could be very interesting but either way
both positions are in need for this team
in Veatch we trust the guy who
discovered Patrick mahomes gets a little
bit of leeway this time
as he decides where to go the Chargers
can't leave the draft without a
quarterback we can agree on that and
make quick work of them sorry Chargers
fans but everybody knows they need a
quarterback is that fair to say that I
don't know I don't agree with that if
you're the Chargers have a top-5 these
residents along a little bit all right
well we're not we're talking football
here they need another offensive tackle
I think I think that's the spot I would
look at you know they traded away
russello Combe I know they got Bulaga
right tackle but I would say spilled I'm
not so sure they have their starting
franchise left tackle on their football
team they have some guys that can still
in but I don't know if there's that guy
I think that's probably where I look at
it with the Chargers and Mike you know
my thoughts are the Chargers and they're
gonna go with Tyrod Taylor then go with
them don't try to win this year don't
waste the number six pick on a
quarterback so what all of you can get
fired out there in LA with the Chargers
and then somebody else can benefit from
the quarterback that just doesn't make
sense to me they need star power at
every position if possible yeah
definitely a quarterback Tyrod Taylor
isn't it and depending upon who's there
at number six you give to a year but
here's the thing if you're concerned
about Tua's health you concerned about
Cam Newton's health I mean they're kind
of in that same mess with both guys who
would be upgrades over Tyrod Taylor
potentially all right Broncos can't
leave the draft without what well it's
two to two spots that really jump out to
me you know inside linebacker or wide
receiver I think are the two that I look
at more than anything to go they need
help at those positions and you know I'm
torn because I look at a guy like Vic
Fangio when he was at Chicago they
drafted ro Quan Smith because that's
what makes that defense go those type of
players that's why he drafted Patrick
Willis and Navarro Bowman when he was in
San Francisco was the D coordinator
there so I'm torn here on which way to
go the defense has enough talent though
I think I'm gonna go with the wide
receiver position
you got drew lock yeah I think he has
special talent I think you agree with
that you got a guy like Courtland Sutton
who's really good too and I just think
they need one more weapon in that pass
game to help out Phillip Lindsey and
Melvin Gordon the run game and
everything they do there and I guess I
would lean with the wide receiver more
than I do the inside linebacker hey I
agree with you completely if you have
your franchise guy and I think they
finally have them in Drew lock you do
what you have to do to help him and you
help him by adding weapons especially a
year like this where there are so many
competent receivers in the draft
although if everybody signs on to that
and they start taking the receivers
maybe there won't be a starting caliber
receiver available for somebody in round
five like Erik Acosta said line well
Mike that's the big question Mike that's
the big question
you know the receivers gonna have a run
in the first round or there's so many
good ones that people will wait and it
won't start with the second round I
think it's one of the fascinating things
of this drab
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports